what's wrong when hey it was cherry my
mom's husband is everything okay
no our mom's dead okay big moment on
Modern Family the death uh-huh what do
you think of the episode did you watch
it I did watch it yeah yeah I know
Chanel I'm a masochist and watch
everything I do um hey I um I thought it
was an amazing episode it made me cry Ed
O'Neill it's just so broken he always
makes me cry it's sad it was tearful but
happy tears and the thing that kills me
the most in that episode was a letter of
howdy tom let's see um on the third
night Dede wandered away from the group
and encountered a pack of starving
timber that episode was great yeah I
hated doing it because normally I'm like
eating prop food when I'm not supposed
to be eating prop food like in between
takes there's something about being
forced to eat that makes you like not
hungry anymore
hey a mat can be pretty hard anyone take
the wrapper off the last one I'm sad
shot there's this theory I'm like having
a lollipop and eating all of the
chocolate and then like spraying with
cream into my mouth from the can and oh
my goodness I I ate my entire weight in
candy and like God bless Sophia I love
her but you couldn't say this one line
and I just kept having like the whipped
cream in my mouth you know I had just
just swallow and like do it again I I
went home and I I was in so much pain I
the worst stomach aches I was like this
is what adults say to you as a kid like
don't eat too much candy it'll upset
your stomach I never understood that
until now I did see Wells here though
him defending you constantly on
Instagram do you love him more for that
he's like my knight in shining armor but
like funny yeah you ever feel like you
want to clap back I mean you do
sometimes oh I do have anime
fanbase and they're all so supportive
and so loving and the only time that I
ever really clap back is when I'm like
ooh this is funny or if it's actually
like putting not someone in their place
but just be kind of like setting the
record straight
sure other than that you know my fan
base takes care of it I don't even have
to do anything that guys are freaking
amazing and then I have wells as well
and but I also I I will say this I
posted something this morning there was
this girl who commented saying that she
has lupus and diabetes and she was
hoping for some words of inspiration
something along the lines of that and
someone told her to go eff off and they
hope that she died in response to her
comments and that is not something that
I am okay with no you can't come after
me you can say whatever you want about
me I can take it to wish death upon
anyone with an illness is absolutely not
OK and I will not stand for that that
person was reported very intensely by me
I like 6:00 o'clock in the morning on a
happier note your birthday's coming up
what are you doing oh you have a wish
list a wish list I don't I have no idea
what I want for my birthday I just want
health and happiness and to eat anything
I want to be able to have a six-pack at
the same time we're gonna be going away
for my birthday so I'm very excited
about that
you